la Nouvelle-Zélande adopté une loi qui
interdit de vendre ou même de fournir
des produits du tabac aux personnes qui
sont nées en 2009 et après ça évidemment
ça touche pour l'instant les jeunes de
14 ans et moins mais éventuellement ça
va toucher les gens de 20 ans 30 ans 50
ans là on veut créer on appelle ça une
génération sans fumer c'est l'objectif
de la loi et nous on s'est demandé
est-ce qu'une disposition pareil
pourrait être adoptée au Canada pour en
parler en juin Patrick Taillon il est
professeur de droit à l'Université Laval
bonjour monsieur Taillon
bonjour alors qu'on interdise la vente
de tabac à des mineurs évidemment ça
scandalise personne mais à des adultes
alors que les autres adultes pourront
toujours continuer d'en acheter il me
semble que c'est de la discrimination
c'est vraiment un colis vraiment très
intéressant pour des questions assez
fondamentales parce que d'une certaine
manière le ce qui semble ce qui est
d'une distinction fondée sur là faut se
demander si c'est vraiment elle a un
effet discriminatoire mais cette
distinction fondée sur l'âge elle est là
pour en quelque sorte tenir compte
prendre en considération le fait que une
fois qu'on est dépendant c'est difficile
d'arrêter donc si on n'a jamais commencé
à fumer puis qu'on dit que le produit
est dangereux qu'on le sort de la
circulation
l'interdiction est et pas de la même
nature et donc c'est fascinant parce
qu'en matière de droits et liberté
souvent on a un système où l'État doit
justifier la raisonnabilité
proportionnalité de son action il doit
montrer que ces actions sont tempérées
par un esprit de compromis et d'une
certaine manière la distinction fondée
sur l'âge ici c'est une forme de
compromis c'est même si la faute est à
la fois le remède j'exagère un peu en
disant cela mais on est en présence
d'une dynamique où on veut en quelque
sorte respecter le fait qu'il y a une
partie de la population qui est
dépendante et une fois qu'il y a qui a
coûté à la toxique la toxicité pardon de
la chose plus difficilement décrocher
bien ça rappelle une longue saga qu'on a
eu au Canada sur la publicité des
produits du
tabaciter sur les paquets publicité en
général et il savait pas assez le test
de la Cour suprême difficilement mais
dans des circonstances où justement il
fallait défendre la limitation de la
liberté d'expression d'un produit dont
la vente est par ailleurs légale
justement on parle juste de la vente et
de fournir des produits et ça se passe
en Nouvelle-Zélande et la question qu'on
se pose à nous ici c'est est-ce que ça
pourrait passer une loi comme celle-là
puisqu'on a une charte des droits alors
est-ce que ça passerait le test
oui évidemment
bon j'ai oublié de le préciser mais la
Nouvelle-Zélande est moins limitée par
des questions de droits et libertés que
les locks qui est le Canada donc pour
moi c'est évident qu'en Nouvelle-Zélande
il y aura probablement pas de problème
puis au Canada c'est plus complexe parce
que justement il faut faire cette cette
mise en balance là l'objectif qui est
poursuivi par l'État qui interdirait si
l'État canadien interdisait la vente de
des produits du tabac il serait
forcément un objectif de santé mais oui
de santé il a d'ailleurs été reconnu
dans les dossiers qui portaient sur la
publicité et ce qui est fascinant c'est
que la mesure serait plus radicale que
l'interdiction de la publicité mais
peut-être plus facile à justifier parce
que du moment où on dit c'est dangereux
pour la santé il faut sortir ça de la
circulation il y a une cohérence dans le
fait de dire
les populations qui sont déjà
on va leur donner une clause grand-père
on leur donner un ACUP et ceux qui ont
jamais goûté on va les protéger
de ce péché alors c'est justement c'est
un objectif qui est louable protéger la
santé de ses concitoyens mais si vous
par exemple vous aviez appelé pour ceux
qui la contestaient la loi si elle
existait qu'est-ce que ce serait vos
arguments
c'est clair que les grandes entreprises
qui pourraient de tabac contesterait une
telle mesure il essaieraient fort
certainement de mobiliser le droit à
l'égalité donc c'est clair ici qu'on a
une distinction fondée sur l'âge mais il
faudrait vérifier c'est pas toutes les
distinctions fondées sur l'âge qui sont
automatiquement similaires de la
discrimination on en quelle mesure il y
a un effet discriminatoire
moi j'en doute on n'est pas en train de
dire que les jeunes ont moins de dignité
comme être humain parce qu'on leur
enlève le tabac du marché et je pense
pas qu'on dise aussi que les personnes
plus âgées sont des personnes moins
dignes et donc c'était fait arbitrage
c'était fait discriminatoire c'est pas
certain qu'il est au rendez-vous et
ensuite de cela l'étape peut toujours se
défendre sur la proportionnalité de son
action donc si nous étions forcés de
représenter les compagnies du tabac on
pourrait essayer de défendre l'idée que
il y a d'autres solutions la prévention
l'investissement
investissement dans des messages
d'intérêt public mais n'empêche que tout
ce qu'on a fait
tout ce qu'on a fait avec la publicité
alors je vous remercie infiniment pour
cette entrevue Patrick Taillon c'est
malheureusement tout le temps qu'on a on
en aurait parlé encore davantage merci
beaucoup au revoir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]